Welcome back to the Athenaeum Book Club
podcast. I'm your host Jeremy Ryan
Slate. I am at Jeremy Ryan Slate on X.
And we've had the pleasure in these
conversations and in covering some
really great books. We recently covered
Thomas More's Utopia. We've covered the
Iliad. But today we have the pleasure of
interviewing a modern author about his
work. And we're very excited to have
Raymond Ibrahim with us today. He's the
author of a number of books, but today
we're going to be focusing on his work
Defenders of the West. I know he has a
upcoming book
soon as well. So we can definitely tell
us about that and where we can expect
it. But Raymond, thank you so much for
hanging out with me today, sir. Yeah, my
pleasure Jeremy. Good to be with you.
Yeah. So the thing I wanted to start
with first and foremost is you've
dedicated much of your career to
studying the long conflict between Islam
and the West. You know, what for you
first sparked this interest? Was it
personal experience or more historical
fascination?
Actually a little bit of both. My own
personal background my I was born here
in the United States, but my family are
Coptic Christians from Egypt. So
obviously there's that long kind of
interaction between my own heritage
Christian heritage with Muslims for 14
centuries in Egypt, which I've always
been interested in intrinsically. And I
ended up majoring in history of course
and naturally I started gravitating
towards the larger question of Muslim
Christian interaction in general, not
just localized in Egypt. And so yeah,
actually as you point out this has
mostly been the focus of my career going
all the way back to my master's thesis,
which I wrote, which was about the very
first major scale battle between
Christians and Muslims. That would be
the Battle of Yarmouk in the year 636.
And I I was working on that before 2001
and then you know, 9/11 happened and all
of a sudden Islam was catapulted. And I
basically continued I did a lot of other
writings and books that that deal with
modern topics, radicalization, Al-Qaeda,
persecution of Christians. But in latter
years I've gone back to my initial
interest, which is history and I've been
producing these books including the one
we'll be talking about.
I find the thing that's interesting in
in listening to some of the
conversations you've had is you make a
point in mentioning that a lot of modern
historians especially with their
influence by the 1960s and and and other
eras in time really tend to want to tell
a different history that that actually
happened during the time of the Crusades
and even even after that.
Yeah.
>> [clears throat]
>> And that was that's one of the reasons
that I really
committed myself to producing these
books that I'm I've been writing because
I see them as correctives
to sort of this sort of hijacking of the
narrative of the history of the West and
Islam. Because like you say
um you know, the new
the sort of new narratives which started
proliferating anytime in the early 20th
century you can say, but really
you know, started gaining steam in the
60s, you know, as everything started
changing and the West is always the bad
guy.
Completely you know, changed it and it
became all of a sudden the Christians
are the bad guys. Islam is peaceful,
more is tolerant, enlightened. And you
know, I always knew better again due to
my own personal experiences. But in
college these were the sorts of books
that I was introduced to. I also went to
Georgetown University, which is really a
bastion of this sort of thing. It's very
pro-Islam. I didn't know that at the
time. But
the thing for me though is I've always
had an interest in the primary sources.
You know, this is why I always emphasize
for people to check the primary sources.
And I know you know, languages and going
back to my days in college. So what I
always found is there's a great
disconnect between what the primary
sources were saying and what these
modern day historians were claiming. And
you know, the long and short of it is
the primary sources is what I produce.
So if you really look at my book it's
very books they're different in that
I don't know, maybe like a third of the
entire text is actual quotes. Okay? And
I do that by design because I it's not
about what I think. I want people to see
what was said historically from the
people who lived, fought and died in
those days. But if you look at a lot of
the you know, best-selling histories you
know, Karen Armstrong used to be very
popular. You won't even find an end note
there and it's just all in her words.
People like John Esposito a lot of them.
And you know, they're New York Times
bestsellers. But when you put them to
the test and compare and contrast them
with what the people who actually live
there say and I mean both Muslims and
Christians. Even the Muslims make it
clear that this was sort of a jihad and
and violence for religious sake etc.
Then the story and the narrative goes
back to the traditional history. A lot
of what they are doing is you know, it's
it's in a way what I'm doing is just
bringing back the original view. Okay? I
mean if you spoke to a European from two
200 years ago or before, what my books
teach would be common sense to them.
They would they would get it because
they had they know of course Islam's a
hostile creed. Yes, Islam conquered
Christendom most of it. Yes, Islam
spread by violence. Yes, we know all
about it. I mean two 300 years ago you
already had Barbary Wars in America and
in Europe you had slave raids from the
Barbary states. So it was still a living
memory.
But
like you said yeah, they've changed it.
They've whitewashed it. They've the
victim is the aggressor and the
aggressor is the victim. And they know
that's par for the course in general
nowadays I think.
Well, as a classicist I can really
appreciate the importance in in reading
primary sources. I know even for my my
grad thesis I did a lot of the research
in in the original Latin and Greek. And
I do think that is really vital because
even the translations can change the
meaning of things, right? So I think
those primary sources are vital.
Yeah, absolutely. And um
you know, it's that used to be the whole
thing back in the day. You know, the
these the Orientalists who were of
course now all demonized as you know,
the patriarchy who's who are
Islamophobes. These guys were you know,
they were polyglots. They were linguists
and philologists and they knew multiple
languages. I mean now your average guy
who who graduates with a PhD doesn't
even know anything other than English.
And you know, and I'm not attacking
that. I'm just saying that they're you
know, those guys really did their
homework and they did it the right way,
which is to deal deal with the primary
sources.
Even if they disagreed they would try to
you know, they would grapple with them.
Nowadays it's just oh yeah, you know,
you know, oh William of Tyre he wrote a
thousand pages about the Crusades. Yeah,
but he was an Islamophobe. Forget it.
You know, that's the kind of pervasive
mentality among so many people, which is
of course which leads to this just
completely distorted view of history.
So your book The Sword and the Scimitar
is is mainly about battles and Defenders
of the West is is more about the men.
I'm curious what made you shift your
focus from the war itself to to those
who actually fought it. Well, I've
always been interested in both and and
various different factors. You know, the
theology that drives both of them. But
Sword and Scimitar was sort of my one
I didn't when I wrote Sword and Scimitar
I wasn't necessarily planning on
following up. And I just wanted to going
back again to my my history days. I mean
my college days and you know, I was a
student of Victor Davis Hanson and he at
the time when I was there you know, he
was writing the book Carnage of Carnage
and Culture, which is about decisive
battles. And so I've always been
interested in decisive battles. That was
the Battle of Yarmouk my master's thesis
I mentioned. So I thought I'd write a
history
about the most decisive battles between
Islam and the West. And but it kind of
grew out of that and it it and I I
realized before long that I had I was
really telling the entire story. It
wasn't just the battles. So every if you
look at I have eight chapters that are
basically around eight battles that I
identify as the most decisive. But
really maybe only 15% of the chapter is
the battle. And the 85% is roughly the
context, which is very very important to
know how it got to that point. And then
when you know, then after that it was a
it was a very successful book and you
know, there was a lot I saw there was a
demand for more. So I decided to instead
of writing just about decisive battles,
now let me write about decisive men
because I think there's a great void in
Western culture
when it comes to finding heroes or
actual men of valor and men who were
decisive, men who believed in something
to fight and die for. So that was you
know, the driving impetus for Defenders
of the West. And you know, it's it's
similar. It follows the same trajectory.
It deals with history and and you know,
the unfolding of the the conflict
between the West and and Islam. But
again through the eyes of various men
that I identify as heroes. And a lot of
them are tragic heroes as well
in the book. But yeah, that was the
driving purpose.
I think it's interesting because that
was a debate that often I went to Seton
Hall here in New Jersey and that was a
debate that that often came up for us in
in grad school was you know, great men
versus forces of history. And I think
when you when you look at history it's a
combination of those two things, right?
Because you do have great men that take
these risks. They are driven by certain
things and it does in a lot of ways
drive the history.
Yeah, yeah. That actually I think his
name was Thomas Carlyle. I believe I
quote him a little bit in Defenders of
the West. You know, one of his
historical views was history is what
great men make of it.
You know, which is of course and that
was the antithesis of I would say
probably the dominant view of history
today, which is a materialistic almost
Marxist view
which completely just ignores ideology,
ignores individuals and supposedly
everything you know, history moves based
on material needs essentially. But I
don't think so. I mean there's room for
both there and and other
interpretations. But I definitely
believe that you know, the movers and
shakers and great men were a pivotal
role in in the in the development of the
world actually and its historical
development.
So when you look at that we talked about
primary sources a few minutes ago. And
when you look at the the sources you
draw and you mentioned you draw on both
Christian and Muslim sources. Um they
often describe very radically different
world views. So I'm I'm curious
um how you reconcile those opposing
opinions when when writing your work.
Yeah, and that's the point. You know, I
want to bring like I said and I say this
in one of the books. I think Sword and
Scimitar. I'll say I spend a lot of
times on the on the on the primary
sources because I want you to know what
the men who fought, lived, and died,
what they thought.
And instead of just you know, what
historians like to do is ignore all that
and then show you how clever they are
because let me tell you what really was
going on. It's not what they say, okay?
>> Trust me, I've had my arguments with
PhDs that tell me I'm stupid, so I get
it. Okay, [laughter] yeah, yeah, you
know what I you know what I'm talking
about.
Um so I didn't want to do that and I
think in one of the books, Defenders of
the West, I say, you know, I'm not I'm
not one of those guys telling you, "Hey,
take my word for it." Here's their
words. And so I wanted to be fair and
balanced and give the Muslims words and
the Muslims views and the Christians
words and the Christians views. And
basically what you find, of course, um
you know, and and that what I found
interesting about that is the
continuity, especially from the Muslim
side. Because the Muslim, you know, all
the all the battles that I discuss in
all these books are initiated really by
Islam, okay, except for the Crusades,
but that too is a rebuttal to Islamic
conquest of Christian territory. Um and
you know, the the rationale and the
logic of those Muslims, and these would
be the caliphs and the sultans and
whatnot, was not unlike ISIS,
which we're told has nothing to do with
Islam, right? So ISIS goes and conquers
and gives people three choices, convert
or be a dhimmi, pay tribute, or get or
die. Well, that's actually how the
caliphates and the sultanates did
operate and that's what they did say and
that's So, you know, so so to me it was
very and it goes all the way up to um
you know, the
I always I always to show how dramatic
this continuity is, I give you a quote
in one of these in I think in Sword and
Scimitar from the Battle of Yarmouk,
which I mentioned, which is in 636,
where uh Khalid bin al-Walid, the sword
of Allah, he basically lays out these
three principles, you know, either we're
here to kill you or you convert or
become, you know, pay us tribute.
And you know, you fast forward from
that, 636 to the year 1800,
and now Thomas Jefferson and John Adams
are trying to figure out why these
Barbary pirates are incessantly
attacking American vessels and enslaving
them, and they meet with a certain
Abdul, who's the Barbary ambassador, and
they say, "Can't we just have trade and
be friends? You know, why why are we
doing this?" And he gives you an exact,
almost quote of what Khalid bin al-Walid
said nearly 12 centuries before. So to
me, that on the Muslim side you have the
unwavering continuity, but what I do
find interesting is on the
Western/Christian side, there's
definitely a break. So the Christians
historically understood all this and to
them they were just they're not going to
pay tribute, they're not going to
convert, so they took the third option,
they fought. You know, tooth and nail
um in various stators of war. The most
famous, of course, is the Holy Land and
the Crusades, but that's not
by any stretch of the imagination the
only one. Spain was essentially a
microcosm of Crusade and Jihad,
Reconquista and and Jihad and and then
you have the Balkans and what happened
there more recently. Um
but so inasmuch as Christians fought,
now it's kind of funny because
Christians uh love to disavow these guys
as bad Christians, you know, oh, how
dare they take up the sword and fight
and they're evil and without realizing
that if it wasn't for those kinds of
guys, they, those Christians today who
are being critical, would probably not
even be Christian. They might be Muslim.
Uh believe it or not and uh this isn't
an exaggeration. Remember that if you
took the entire Christian world in the
7th century when Islam was born, about
three quarters of it was permanently
conquered and no one would have thought
that was possible. And it was the older,
richer, more sophisticated, more learned
regions, which would be Egypt and Syria,
Asia Minor later on, all of North
Africa. This was the heart of
Christendom, not Europe. Europe was sort
of the little brother. But Europe is all
that remained after the 7th century
Jihad, okay? And um
anyway, so the the discontinuity between
modern Christians and their forebears is
what's very interesting um and it's
what's leading to the problems that you
see today because whereas uh you know,
the Europeans of that time, of course,
understood Islam and fought and resisted
it, today you can't even say anything
about Islam and you have to flood
Western nations like Western Europe with
Muslim migrants and then lo and behold,
they act like
they did before and you have violence
and now you have to suppress your own
native population from noticing it and
it's a big huge mess. So, yeah.
It's it's interesting because it's you
have to figure out is it postmodernism
that got us here? Is it political
correctness that got it here? But at the
same point we can't talk about a lot of
the issues we're dealing with or it's
seen as offensive or wrong and I don't
know how you handle a problem or a
situation unless you can actually talk
about what's occurring.
Yeah, and this has become a real issue
above and beyond the Islam issue. I
mean, the Islam issue is a big point,
but you know, this this sort of
domineering culture of what we can and
can't talk about and
you know, and if you say the wrong
thing, you know, who you get canceled
and whatnot. I think I think it's it's
losing it's but I think that kind of
approach is dying out. It's become
obvious what it is and too many people
are seeing through it. So it's best that
like you say, you you're not going to
solve any problem unless you can be
honest and talk about it. And the idea
that oh, you we we can't hear this guy
or this guy can't say that. Well, I
mean, that's pure censorship.
Yes.
You know, why don't we hear what they
have to say and then say, "Oh, you're
wrong for this, that, and the other
reason." That's a better approach.
Well, I guess looking at the the the
moral complexity of these of the
characters you talk about. So in
profiling these figures, you describe
some as saints and others as more
complex or even as as sinners in a way.
How do you navigate these moral
ambiguities in the stories while also
highlighting their role in in really
defending the West?
Yeah, um so my point, you know, I don't
and I I I I I think I'm paraphrasing
what I wrote in the introduction as to
how I approach this, but basically I'm
not reading these men's hearts. I don't
know.
And if they said they're Christian and
if they said they're doing this on
behalf of Christendom, that was good
enough for me.
Okay, and and the men that I profiled
all did that. In fact, all all the
Christian fighters in the pre-modern era
did and said that. So I can't, you know,
I don't know what was in their heart,
but basically from from their actions,
and that's what Jesus said, right? You
will know them by their fruits, not so
much by their words. Well, it definitely
seemed like they were fighting on behalf
of Christendom and Christians and trying
to defend them. And
by the theology of that time, that was
absolutely a Christian thing to do.
You know, it's
We can get That's actually
that's actually more of the topic of my
recent book, The Two Swords of Christ,
because I get into that verse where
Jesus says two swords are enough and how
it was understood, but long and short of
it is basically self-defense was in no
way, shape, or form something that
Christians had problems with until now.
Yeah. And I think now it's mostly
because they're just trying to make a
virtue of a vice, which is cowardice and
complacency, and patting themselves on
the back and saying, "Look, I'm a good
Christian because I'm never
confrontational." when in fact they're
just cowards.
Um so I think that's kind of what's
going on right now.
So I guess then looking at like some of
those characters, so so Godfrey, for
example, um his refusal to wear the the
crown of gold where Christ wore a crown
of thorns is one of the most powerful
moments in Crusader history.
What does this tell about the medieval
idea of of kingship, but also of faith?
You know, before I get into that cuz you
mentioned a good point about Godfrey, I
want to say something and just again to
show you. So Godfrey, I included him,
he's chapter one, chronologically he's
one of the earliest. And you know, if
you read it the account, very heroic,
very noble, very magnanimous, very
faithful, and very fierce, okay?
And as as you just said, he was he, you
know, he he very notably said I when
they wanted to make him the first king
of Jerusalem and he said he refused the
the title and he
he refused to wear a a crown of gold
where my savior, he said, wore a crown
of thorns. Okay, very modest. Now,
here's how the modern take on Godfrey
is. I read in you know, Sir Runciman,
Steven Runciman's
he has a I think three volume mega
volume on the Crusades, which was very
influential, but happily a lot of
historians now are sort of, you know,
exposing it for its very anti sort of
Crusade, anti-Christian, pro-Islamic,
definitely uh
very, very pro-Byzantine point of view,
at least vis-a-vis
the Crusaders, but be that as it may, he
basically in one sentence summarizes
Godfrey as just a fool, a naive fool and
a simpleton.
Wow.
You know, and and he just dismisses him.
And if you just go by Runciman, like so
many people do, of course, you're you're
you're going to be yeah, what a what an
idiot this guy was, you know, he was
apparently because he would listen to
Christian monks.
Uh so he was he didn't have any real
sense of realpolitik and so forth. Um so
but
to your larger question,
>> [clears throat]
>> excuse the cat, to your larger question
>> it?
I I I had
Colonel Douglas McGregor on the show
last year and his cat was actually like
looking for something behind him the
whole time and I had comments all going
down YouTube where they're figuring out,
"What's the cat doing now?" So don't
worry about it. Yeah, all right. Well,
it's right now like playing with my
feet, but anyway,
um so I'm sorry, I got distracted. Your
point again was the difference and the
faith of Christian
>> ideas of medieval kingship, but also of
faith and and and how we can see Godfrey
as an example of that. Yeah, well, so
the faith of these early Christian kings
and the Crusaders, um sorry about this,
but That's okay. Uh the the the their
faith was very stalwart, very sincere,
and that was actually how their kingship
was justified. And that's why they were
seen as good kings. You know, Godfrey is
just one, and like I said, he's not even
considered the first king technically
because he wasn't um uh the first king.
He was the first he
the title that he took on was the
defender essentially. Uh or the advocate
of the Holy Sepulchre. And um
>> [laughter]
>> This must look This is hilarious.
>> look ridiculous, I know, but you know,
whatever. It's It's It's a constant with
these animals around me. But
But anyway, but you know, if you look at
other other kings that I highlight in
that book, for example, Louis, Saint
Louis the ninth.
Man, I mean, that guy was literally You
see why they call him a saint
um because he just you know, he would do
things like even though he was one of
the most powerful and richest men in
Europe, he would you know, make sure
that every once in a week or something
like that, they would bring the
dirtiest, poorest, ugliest, you know,
most miserable homeless people so he can
wash their feet and and um feed them
with his hands.
>> Wow. And he preferred them to be blind
so they wouldn't know who he was and
then go and spread rumor about him in
other words, praise him because he
wanted it to be in anonymity. Okay, so
that Imagine that was a king. And
there's a lot a lot of that, but the
problem is today it's
>> different than comparing him to like
somebody like Henry Tudor or something
like that.
>> Right. Yeah, yeah. He's very involved in
himself. It is. But also, one of the
problems um and this now goes sort of a
Hollywood, you know, the the idea that
I'm saying is so unintelligible to most
people because we've watched Hollywood
movies and every king or every noble who
um you know, especially anyone who's
holding a cross and talking about
religion is the biggest hypocrite, he's
the most despicable person. I'm telling
you, every movie you watch, that is the
theme. So, what I'm saying is probably
very hard for people to even believe.
But again, I'm going by the sources. If
you read what the sources say,
uh these guys come out very pious, very
observant, very strict and religious.
And again, so what do what do what do um
you know, historians who don't want you
to believe that say? Oh, that's just
hagiography. That's not a true you know,
the the people who wrote that about him
are making it up. We all know he's he
was a you know, a materialist and a
hedonist because that's what kings do.
No, that's what Hollywood tells you. And
of course, there have been kings and
nobles and and you know, decadent
people. I'm not arguing that. But that
shouldn't also make us
you know, by default conclude that never
can you find a good Christian king
because there were many of them. Well,
and I think there it goes back to what
we're talking about about heroes, right?
You look like somebody like, you know,
Henry the fifth or some of these
characters in history that that are very
strong characters. It It It almost seems
like now, if you look at modern kind of
the way things are done, it's almost a
hero's journey in reverse, which is kind
of weird. Where somebody can't become a
heroic figure in a lot of ways.
Yeah. I mean, heroism is under attack
right now. Um I talked about it
recently, too, about Get off me, man.
This thing.
Sorry about that.
Um
I talked about it recently, you know,
there's this anti-hero thing and you see
it in a lot of um for example,
literature. And I mentioned this
recently, I remember in the high school
um I don't know if you're you're
probably young for this, but there was a
book called Grendel. I was born in the
mid I was born in the mid 80s, so I'm
I'm not as young as I look. Okay. Okay.
All right. Well, anyway, there was this
book called Grendel and it was so
instead of reading Beowulf, okay, which
is you know, written it's it's
historical, uh we were we read Grendel.
And And now this is the Of course, for
those who don't know, Beowulf is a hero
and he fights a monster Grendel. And in
in the in the saga, he's you know, it's
very black and white who's good and
who's bad. Okay.
Uh but in this Grendel, it's written
from his viewpoint, the monster. And all
the And he's misunderstood and you know,
seeing it from his eyes, look how evil
Beowulf is and so forth. And you know,
that's all well and good, fine to see
the um to to get the other alternative
viewpoint, but
in it's kind of become like the thing
now, you know, where And again, you see
this in Hollywood, like the guy that's
supposed to be good is really bad. Okay,
deep down inside. And the guy that's
really bad, evil, he's like kind of
really good, just misunderstood. So,
it's sort of this intentional um you
know,
you know,
overturning the idea of heroism and
villainy, you know, good and bad, black
and white. It's completely under attack.
And you know, the more someone tries to
be heroic, then he's really evil, he's
really bad, he's toxic masculinity, he's
the patriarchy, he's etc., etc. So,
yeah, that is the current climate.
Get off.
>> Well, I think talking about some of
those that that especially modernly have
been given a bad name. I think Vlad
Tepes is a is a a good good example of
that. You know, he's given the moniker
Vlad the Impaler and we're supposed to
see him in a certain way when we look at
the the modern light. So, when we look
at Eastern defenders like Vlad,
um you know, how do these Eastern
defenders teach us about, you know,
impossible odds and resistance under
those odds? Well, you know, there it is.
It's in the proximity. The Eastern
defenders of Europe, the ones who were
further east than the west. Why is that?
Because they were much closer to Islam.
And they actually experienced If you
were living in the East Europe, all
right, where Romania or Wallachia,
Hungary, the Balkans, you have much more
experience with Islam in the guise of
the Ottoman Turks especially than if you
were living in France. Uh France
actually would ally with the Ottomans
and it was very scandalous I think in
the 17th century and onwards or even
before that. But um so that's why you
get a lot of viciousness and savagery
from Eastern Europeans because that they
were dealing You have to fight fire with
fire. You know, Halloween just came and
I did a live stream about Dracula, you
know, both the fictitious one and the
real one. And a lot of the reasons that
Vlad Tepes the Impaler is is so
demonized, again, it's pulled out of
context. You're not told that first he
was actually taken as a hostage, he and
his and his brother by the Ottomans,
abused. His brother was sexually abused
and turned into basically a catamite.
Yeah.
>> And you know, he was in prison for years
being tortured. He He witnessed how the
Ottomans would execute people, which
included impalement. And then when he
was finally freed and and living in and
and becoming the the leader of Wallachia
at the time,
he had to fight fire with fire. And he
was much smaller force, much weaker, you
know, the odds of his army versus the
Ottomans was like 1 to 10. Okay, so he
would engage in what we would call today
guerrilla warfare, terror tactics, and
especially trying to frighten them by
impalement. And so he really did have a
forest of impaled, which when the
Ottomans came and saw it, they actually
the the sultan decided I'm done and he
left.
>> Well, it's a deterrent in a way, right?
Like you see that, like you're you're
not going to mess with Vlad. Right. And
that that was the whole that's his
character. That's why till today,
Romanians like him. He tends to be in
the top 10 most revered Romanian figures
of history.
Um he's seen as the no-nonsense guy. As
long as you follow the rules, you know,
you're fine. But one false move, yeah,
you'll get staked.
Well, I guess looking at the the modern
relevance a bit more, um
do you think modern leaders of the West
have have lost the civilizational
awareness um that these men had? And
where do you think those are the What do
you think are the dangers in actually
forgetting that? Well, yeah, of course
they've lost it. Modern Western leaders
are essentially grossers.
>> [laughter]
>> You know,
they're lawyers. They They They don't
have much masculinity or any any sense
of manhood whatsoever, honestly. And
again, I'm I'm speaking very generally
and there may be good ones here and
there.
Um but by and large as a class, you
know, the politicians are just uh
You know, the They're I mean,
the person who wants to be a politician
already is a flawed individual in a way
because there's just uh They're looking
for wealth and power in a lot of ways.
Yeah, I think Plato said the ideal
philosopher king is the one that you got
to hunt him down and force him, right,
to be a king. Not someone who's going
out of his way and getting money and
making promises so he can win, right?
And that's kind of what we have today.
So, yeah, I think
what we're talking about defenders of
the West and all that, that is not
something that you will see in the
ruling political class of the West,
hence why things are the way they are
right now, of course.
So, what do you think are the dangers
then in in kind of forgetting this this
way of being and and the kind of legacy
of these defenders?
Well, the danger is, you know, the West
is at historically its strongest moment
militarily, financially, economically,
um structurally, in all ways, right? And
yet it's being terrorized and beaten and
demoralized left and right by weak
people. The You have to remember, Islam
today is a weak, spent force. It's only
a threat when people make it a threat.
So, historically, Islam would invade,
let's say, Europe and try to get in and
conquer and kill and enslave, and they
fought back. Now, Islam can't do that.
But for example, in the UK, I hear
people complaining, "Oh, Muslims are
invading." No, they're not. Sorry.
They're being welcomed in and they're
being given everything they want and
they're being enabled.
And when they commit crimes, the you
know, the powers that be cover up for
them. And when you as a native Brit
object, then you're the bad guy and you
go to prison because you said something
uh true.
Uh so, the problem now is is that on the
one hand, like I said, the West is so
powerful vis-a-vis the Islamic world um
and most in fact, the whole world
really, and yet because of its weak
leadership, you know, it's being beaten,
it's being terrorized in its own
homeland, right? And And you And And
this is very obvious if you look at
other countries that just uh you know, I
usually point to Poland and Hungary,
even though that may be changing. They
don't have an Islam problem. Women can
walk at night without feeling they're
going to be raped like in Western Europe
because they just said, "No, we don't
want Muslims." Or they have very strict
you know, very limited numbers that
they'll take in, whereas in Western
Europe, oh yeah, like I said, just bring
them in and
and I think in all of Budapest, which is
something like 2 million people, there's
one mosque. Imagine that, right?
>> Wow. Yeah. So, um it's it's the Islam
today, like I always say, Islam has
always been Islam and you know, the
Islamic hostility for the infidel is
always there, but
but um
but uh it's now it's weak and it's being
enabled, you know? So, it's not it's not
doing what it's doing the way it did
historically by force. It's it's it has
uh uh uh um
it has people who are actually who are
not Muslim, I imagine, um and who are
just enabling and allowing them to get
away with all that sort of thing.
Well, I guess when we look at key
takeaways, when we look at Defenders of
the West and and the struggle and and
the ideology of it,
what are the enduring things we can
learn from, you know, the work of
Defenders of the West?
Well, those men, first and foremost,
like I said, they were Christian in the
sense that
what they were doing was in the name of
Christianity, including just you know,
defending their homeland, defending
their faith, their families, their
culture, their civilization.
All of that. Uh
I guess it comes down to these guys had
something that they believed in and that
was worth fighting for.
Which I don't think is evidence now, you
know, what's worth fighting for today
for your average Western man? You know,
he's he's being browbeaten left and
right because he shouldn't even be a
man, I guess, at this point. Uh
so,
uh so I think the enduring legacy or
what can be learned is um a return, uh
you know, to normal, healthy thinking
and uh uh you know,
being a normal person. The way those
guys were was organic. It's the way that
every guy is outside the West. You know,
I always say that, you know, what's
called the alt-right,
that is basically the default character
traits of everyone who's non-Western.
You know, think about it, what is it?
Patriotic, my way, my culture comes
first, um you know, whatever uh
patriarchy, etc. That's the whole world.
What liberalism is the idea of
liberalism, I think, has softened men in
a lot of ways.
>> Yeah, exactly. Completely. And it wasn't
evident in the men that I write about in
Defenders of the West. So, I think
that's uh liberalism is just a complete
poison, a toxic that has completely uh
emasculated men. So, something like the
characters that appear in Defenders of
the West are just uh complete
aberrations now.
Well, you mentioned um as we started
recording here that you do have a new
book coming out. So, I'd love to hear
about what you're working on now and
then also the the new book you have
coming out. Sure. Well, the new book is
right here. It's uh the
the two swords of Christ.
Um the subtitle is The Five Centuries of
War Between Islam and the Warrior Monks
of Christendom.
And uh
talking about ubermen, that this is what
this book's about. It's about the
military orders, especially the the
Knights of the Temple and the Hospital.
And these guys took uh
you know, these guys took heroism and
manhood to another level, much more than
the guys in Defenders of the West, as
good as they are.
Um because And what's interesting about
this new book is I really get into the
theology, so that that they actually it
was justified from a theological point
of view, despite what modern-day
Christians think nowadays that, you
know, oh, that theology in no way, shape
or form uh supports violence in any way,
shape or form, again.
Um so, yeah, that's that book and
what I'm working on now is uh
Uh I'm actually recovering now from that
book. It's uh it's all it's 500 pages,
you know, so my gosh. Yeah, I'm just
taking a little break and recalibrating
and thinking about what I'll probably be
writing next.
I I'm mid Decline and Fall of the Roman
Empire, so I've I'm I'm committing a a
significant amount of time to to Gibbon
right now. [laughter]
Edward Gibbon's all right.
>> volume. Yeah, yeah.
No, that's that's actually a good thing
to read.
It's it's interesting because too, if
you look at um like his language, even
post-World War language, it actually for
the modern reader is so different, which
is I think very interesting cuz it shows
a lot of the eloquence we've lost.
>> It's very elegant, it's very articulate,
uh
yeah, that's why almost I tell people
when I read, you know, most I have a
cutoff date, usually if it's if it's I I
prefer before 1900s, anything I read.
But I'll I'll go into maybe 1950s.
Anything after that is probably I'm
reviewing a book and I have to read it,
but I usually stay away from all the uh
you know, the new stuff. I recently
looked at the top 100 bestsellers on
Amazon and I was just
You'd have to put a gun to my head to
make me read any of those and I'm a
bibliophile, you know, so.
Well, one final question I want to take
a look at cuz I know uh we have to get
you out for another conversation you're
having, but um
we talked a little bit about
politicians, but I just want to talk a
little bit about that Western man as
we're as we're coming in here for for a
landing, but you spent years studying
men who lived in faith, honor and duty.
Do you think the modern world still
produces that kind of man or can produce
that kind of man?
Oh, I think it can produce that kind of
man. I think that is man by default. In
other words, if you let man alone, that
is what he becomes. It's but we are
living in a socially engineered system
where you're not supposed to be that and
from the moment you're born, all the
public education and the TV programming
is designed to make you not become that,
okay? Um so, so it's definitely the good
news is it's there. It's in it's it's
inborn in every man, just like uh
being feminine is inborn in every woman,
but unfortunately, the West is under
extreme assault through this social
engineering sort of project to turn them
into the opposite of what they are. I
mean, this transgender nonsense as one
example that that we're even talking
about that, you know, instead of just
laughingly just dismissing it, uh just
shows you how how far the rot has gone.
Yeah. It's one of the major reasons that
we're we're homeschooling our kids cuz
it's just that I'm I'm a little
terrified of of what the school system
looks like at the moment. Good for you.
Yeah.
Well, Raymond, I appreciate you spending
some time with us today and for those of
those people listening to the audio um
and not seeing the video, you're going
to miss out on this cat that has been
very interesting through this entire
conversation.
But where can people find out more about
you and where can people find out more
about your work?
Yeah, thanks. Um my website,
RaymondIbrahim.com,
you know, is my one-stop place, but you
can also find me on YouTube and I've got
videos there, um the Holy War channel,
also under my name.
Um so, yeah, check them out. And uh get
get Defenders of the West and The Two
Swords of Christ. I think um you know,
that people will really like them.
Absolutely. And reminder for those of
you out there watching to like this
video, leave us a comment and also smash
that subscribe button to help us make a
bigger impact out there. We have a few
more modern authors coming on, which I'm
excited for as well in the next couple
of weeks.
>> We we are grateful to to Raymond Ibrahim
for joining us today. So, Raymond, thank
you so much for hanging out and reminder
for everyone to go grab his new book,
The Two Swords of Christ, and thanks for
spending some time today.